all right. If you've never seen hatred mail
before, hatred mail is when a professional
voiceover artist does interpretive readings.
Of the hatred mail. I receive quick reminder
about hatred mail,
because the government that is supposedly
totally inept is the same government that
can pull off a conspiracy that'll blow your
mind.
Hey Trey, it mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom
and let's get directly directly into this
week's hatred mail, which is riddled of course
with antisemitism, but also simple misunderstandings
about the nature of reality around us.
David Pakman is a typical Jew. He's smearing
white people as the problem. Again, David
shill for the Jew, KU Hackman. Hey David,
you're psychology isn't working. Playing the
good Jew isn't going to stop the inevitable.
Oh, and by the way, the stock market is up
well over 27,000 points. That's the real is
real.
So listen, the, uh, the stock market is not
up more than 27,000 points. It is true that
the Dow Jones has surpassed the 27,000 level,
but the stock market is not up 27,000 points.
Clearly, someone who is very eager to spout
talking points that they whore, heard, sort
of, but don't really understand. But you've
got to understand the talking points if you
want to do a good job of parroting them. Also
smearing white people. What are you talking
about? The David Pakman show, smearing white
people. Uh, I think it would be good to re
review some of our material. You must have
as mistake mistaken for some other show. Remember
that the best way to fight hatred, schism
is to use the coupon code hatred at 40. Whenever
you sign up for a membership@joinedpackman.com
you save 40% the hate free. It's cry because
their hate messages are, are just uh, impotence.
They are unable to make any headway. That
code is spelled H, a T R. I. O T four zero.